you've clicked by and your online
purchase is complete
but Betty BOTS work is just beginning
she's a Kiva robot at quiet logistics
fulfillment center
behind every online store is a warehouse
full of merchandise one is quiet
logistics where there are one and a half
million items stored
it's Betty BOTS job to retrieve your
purchase and she can do this faster and
more accurately than any human ever
could when you buy something online your
order enters the Kiva database the
software locates the robot closest to
your item and directs her to retrieve it
using a network of barcodes on the floor
she navigates the 300,000 square foot
warehouse tunneling beneath the pods as
she moves throughout the grid
when Betty bot reaches her target she
slides beneath the pod and lifts it off
the floor
she carries your purchase through the
warehouse streets this area is called
the human exclusion zone where no human
may enter there are 100 Kiva robots
operating autonomously on the floor and
the quiet logistics crew boasts some of
the fastest robots in the business
peanut butter butter rum Juke bot bot BQ
and Walter Cabot the fourth even in
heavy traffic their sensors keep them
from colliding the server constantly
monitors and coordinates the bots
activity it makes sure the fleet is
operating at peak productivity and
responds to changing consumer demand
throughout the day it even eliminates
bottlenecks at the shipping area where
human workers ready your purchase for
shipment to your door
the entire process takes as little as 15
minutes from click to ship in a given
day the robot crew will fetch up to
30,000 orders four times the volume of
standard fulfillment centers and they're
99.99% accurate they're also highly
efficient requiring only five minutes
out of every hour to recharge the bots
are designed to do tasks that humans
would be hard-pressed to complete
covering 12 miles of ground per day
operating 24 hours a day 365 days a year
forever changing the way our economy
moves from the warehouse to your house